so today actually every day is a daily
blitz arena
but i'll be playing this tournament it's
two hours of five minute blitz
and i figured that i'll play a different
gambit
every game
and this will just be my
my gambit list
welcome to those of you joining early
have black in the first game
illuminati
oh thank you md for prez
uh i gotta start with a stafford right
staff or gamut time
it's kind of risky
his opponent's higher rated than me
only plays blitzen and classical or
blitz and rapid
but we have the
main position of stafford
playing h5
there's also g5 or b5
but uh
yeah i'm
i'm gonna try and at least get a
playable position
white's playing actually a very good
line like h3 and queen e2
i think is usually what the engine
recommends
hey thank you blunder pro king's gambit
let's go i could try and deliver on that
can i go for queen d7 castling queenside
queen d7 prevents white from castling
because it's tied down to
defending the pawn knight d1 wow
uh so white wants to play this and this
i would like to
[Music]
be aggressive here
i think i'll start with this move and c3
i'll play this and maybe even c4 later
control the d3 square
we have an interesting it's kind of like
a high level stafford
like white's playing very
prophylactically
but a little bit passively
and i'm down the pawn but
i got my pieces developed
ready to queenside castle
white was threatening some annoying a5
so d3 that makes sense it's castle
okay i see a lot of uh
a lot of people's favorite gambits being
shared in chat
welcome back mark valloy
yeah c5
if i make some sense
from gambit 4 move oh no my queen works
every time
[Music]
i'm thinking this move too
but i don't want to remove my queen from
[Music]
let's just put a rook in the center
also there's some really loud like
drilling going outside my window but
i hope this sounds okay i'm using a
noise suppression filter so
um hopefully there's not too much
annoyances
knight c3 okay
uh maybe bishop bishop d4 if takes i
take with queen and then find a square
on b4 for the queen
[Music]
sound is good okay good to hear
and good to see
f4
oh it's playing as well
i have this move
because f5 was a threat
i probably want to play king b8
following the ben feingold rule
queensland castling is unexpected
it's here i can take and um maybe go
into the a3 square
i'm also allowing for this maneuver
going after the pawn
[Music]
it's risky because white's going to have
a massive center but hey nice chess
oh thank you pbk live
we're trying to play nice chess
currently we're playing down upon chess
because that's the nature of staffer
gambit
uh
if i play this the bishop will take
i think king b8
is slow and steady
but not too slow
wait what
like giving back a pawn
oh tactics
i'm in trouble
or am i
i'm in trouble i was clever
yeah this move's coming
or not
i'm so flustered by white's moves
so there's this pressure
um
there's also this threat which is
massive now
so how do i defend
do i have a defense
hi again eric
hi again
oh i'm in trouble
there
i'm thinking this and then b6
i mean c6 is left very very vulnerable
but what else to do
this could end really really badly if
this i have 95
oh i meant to play i should play b6
first
i guess i'm allowing check here here
knight b8
or that move first but now i have 95
and if this i fork
oh but e5 is not defended
but white's taking time
yeah this is just really bad for me
uh
do i resign let's play this move
what rook b5
will just move
rook b5 is insane
i'm going to lose my queen
the hope is to get like some
compensation
bishop takes c6
what is white doing
very strange play
uh is there so many like simple ways to
win
am i just losing here
i might just be losing
i have this move though
problem is king
let's try this i have 22 seconds
the king a1 rook team on
should see one
absolutely crazy play
okay i've
i could have resigned that was such a
weird game
especially the finish
rook b5 top move
bishop
it's like how do you
and that was made in 10 after
oh this is already force mate
hello everyone wow
yeah cause the simple move is to take
the queen and be up a queen
but bishop takes c6 as made in 14
[Music]
so
uh uh yeah to play like king a1 bishop
c12
uh
wow
hello eric greetings from right down the
road in memphis
oh greetings
greetings from st louis i think this was
an example of how to refute the staffer
gambit
hello eric i have a challenge for you in
a rapid game boat has gambit against me
bit have its
1400 on leeches as soon as possible in
the opening if you win i'll gift five
subs if i win you promote my youtube
channel
okay um i might be down for that but
i'm a little bit preoccupied here
playing against the king's gambit
yeah unfortunately i don't have time to
check the previous game too closely
but definitely requires some
maybe uh
investigation analysis
um anyway
let's
do i go for
i'm trying to play a museo but i don't
think this is how you play the museo
i play this move 96
takes and then takes
uh okay
i'm so tilted from the last game
i'm going a little bit insane this game
is it count close now really
cool on dragon dragon dragon dragon
dragon dragon dragon
i don't know if i get rating refund if
they like beat me and then close account
before they get uh
flagged for
for engine use
or maybe did they get flagged and then
they close account
um yeah i was a pretty obvious uh engine
user
i usually don't like i don't accuse
someone until it's like confirmed but
i know what to do
king e7 okay so
uh what is this position
i want to play b3
i think i'll play b3
with a sneaky threat
hey i got my rating refund
in this move first
okay here's my rating
refund uh what a way to start this
stream
i wonder
i i guess i still got a zero for the
tournament standings because i didn't
actually win
um
yeah it's not too common that i play
engine users and lists
it happened on their day in classical
chess
i should update my chrome yeah
can do that later
okay so bishop a3 was a main idea but i
think i'll play this first
hey eric
thanks for all your contents you're
great oh you're great too thank you phil
also thank you it's me mahou
i feel like i'm making some progress
here
i'm down a piece but i have almost
everything
developed except my rooks and my king
but i have like sneaky knight moves now
and the queen is tied down to the bishop
oh yeah black wants a queen train
i just want to checkmate the king
somehow
can you play lukini gabbit i could try
haven't played one of those in a
while now b7 is hanging but then bishop
c6
um i think i'll play knight knight e4
just such a nice square
so i'm playing around the black pawns
also hitting c5 now three times
and the b-pawn is pinned to the rook and
the bishop is pinned to the king
so
some nice things happening here
knight f6
uh if i take again bishop d6 thanks for
all the awesome entertainment eric you
are a legend ever since the start of
kovid you made me fall back in love with
chess i stay here
thank you baby
trying to figure out what to do here i
want to take
takes and then take
hit the king take the queen
[Music]
it's not so clear though
and 9 6 was a good move
oh if i take
i'm spending a lot of time here but
it's a tricky situation
i think i might just take and castle
and then just leave black pinned in
various directions and the queen is now
tied down to this pawn
there is a move queen d6 but then i take
and if here i move away
okay so we enter that line
oh there's a funny line d4
i don't know if it works though because
pawn takes i was thinking takes take
some pin but
it wouldn't be a pin because there's a
knight here
what is going on here
i could play c3
maybe this move
oh do we have tea today no but we have
ice water
is my tea for the day
it's getting warmer in st louis
i'm gradually slowing down with warm
drinks and
transitioning to cold drinks
oh yeah this move looks fun now
sacking a lot of things this game
so that i could take the pawn but then i
have rook e6
i'm trying to get rid of ponds because
they get in the way of my my pieces
wait warm drinks help you keep you cool
what if i'm already cool
this position is kind of cool
threatening the queen threatening this
check
although this rook on aid is defended by
the bishop
from far away
long-distance relationship
i'm hoping for queen c7 i might have
made in one
oh what was opening this game it was a
king's gambit
turned into fuckbear counter gambit
turned into
whatever this is
i'm realizing the queen doesn't have a
good place to go wait is the queen
trapped
oh the queen is trapped if it moves here
it's made it moves here at skewer
uh
am i mating
i'll just win the queen
hello eric good evening from vienna
smile oh good evening from st louis
or good afternoon from st louis
uh welcome to max thanks for subbing
comes take a pawn
oh
now i'll try and
rotate my way around
hi eric love your content
oh i love you too thank you
aquara gola
thanks for subbing for 10 months
okay a lot of things just came off the
board
i'll be winning on time
position is also winning
oh can i mate
ah okay
uh
that was a weird game
okay so the gamut so far
i've played staff or gambit
oh it gave me points
i guess that's that's what happens when
you lose to someone who uses an engine
not only did my rating get refunded but
i've
it counted as a win because
opponent was playing unfairly so staffer
gambit and
uh whatever i just played king's gambit
craziness
okay
i'm still not top hundred because i've
had long more long games
i only played two games so far
a leader has played four
okay i see all the requests in chat
budapest and ackmanson
need some black gambits
uh
okay take my pawn i just want a gambit
take my pawn
i don't know what this gambit is but
i'm just trying to get rid of my pawn so
my pieces have
open lines
and now i play this move
trying to deflect the bishop from
defending the knight
i want to play this move next
uh
this is such a funny opening i'm
threatening to trap the bishop
it's not easy for white to stop this
hello eric i am your long-lost brother
as i am the son of your father and
magnus carlson's mother i will be the
best chess player to ever live while
exclusively playing the stafford gambit
also quack also with coin
so the son of my father is magnus
carlson's mother
what
also what about bitcoin
uh
here here
not quite trapping the bishop
i don't really want to trade queens
i think i'll start with this and then
[Music]
deliberate
maybe just calmly and calmly feeding
keto
so these ponds just trap in the night
night wants to develop here but the pond
is stuck because of this knight
and the knight is blocking the bishop as
well
f3 i guess is logical
now do i take the bishop
maybe
but maybe not
there's queen d4
there's knight a6
maybe i'll play knight a6
idea knight c5
i'm not playing g7 because i want to
keep the the file open for my queen
it's fun having fresh positions from
very early on
okay uh i think we'll
hmm this pawn is kind of
it's kind of tender
i think i'll take this thing first
if takes i win the night if takes
then i i take
and then take
and then castle queenside
and then in the very end knight b4 and
i'm going to be winning
the pawn and or the
rook hey thank you bob barker
oh it's a famous bomb barker
from uh
it's bob
from the gotham stream
i appreciate the gifted subs i was
watching uh gotham's analysis
on your brilliancies earlier
bob aka shawn wait what do i call you
bob or sean
or sean bob
okay where's my mate
everything's pinned
the only thing that can move is a king i
think i'll start with this move
and after this i'll play this
and white will be completely stuck
it's so funny
white's going to be in zugsvan
he just has no moves
i'm also just writing this move
or i'm trying this and then this
now i have a double battery pin along
the first
rank and that would be uh pretty
be pretty pleasant
it's hard to talk when this position is
so good
all stemmed from
[Music]
such a weird opening h5 d5 g5
i feel a little bit bad
but even more good
okay where's the meat
oh there's a funny mate
threatening maiden one
or no made in two
white's still completely stuck
uh
am i mating
i'll take this first and then take here
oh it has one legal move yeah
threatening the knight as well
no no no no no no no no i was a mouse
slip
my keyboard got in the way of the mouse
oh no
my funny position is ruined
i'm so sad now never mind the checkmate
okay
and so you have to treat every blunder
as a gambit
what just happened there
white's doing fine i think after 92 and
then the h punk and start rolling
i want to finish the game
[Music]
that's why you don't resign because
mouse loops do sometimes happen
i'm using a wireless keyboard
and somehow it shifted right next to my
mouse so i couldn't move my mouse all
the way
also quack and my mouse like ran into
the keyboard and then i release a click
i have to move my keyboard further away
thank you bill maze
okay so that was uh
h5 vs g3 now what do i play let's start
with e4 again
um
can i play a gamut against this
it's a purits
uh
[Music]
how do i gamut against this opening
g4 at some point probably
we'll start normally
oh
this is a um
the simon williams like black lion type
thing
okay i'll find a way to gambit
can i gamble my queen
that would be the ultimate gambit
i'm gonna gamble my queen
oh no my queen
oh it looks fun though
okay so the king has two options
regardless of where it moves i'll play
knight e6
and now
i'm down the queen but i have a knight
in bishop
in black's crib
and now i probably just take the bishop
i could take it with my knight even
say with knight or king
uh probably king only keep my night
developed
i lose casting rights
okay
oh i want to have fun here e5
it's all about having fun
okay so we trade once
we avoid trades of knights
the goal is to line up everything on the
e-file
uh i have another pawn
why not
oh black might want to trade with me
again i'm trying to get rid of pawns
because they get in the way of
things
i got rid of my queen kind of for the
same reason
my king was jealous of
the queen sitting on d1
now i probably want to get a rook to d1
uh
do i bond cloud
let's blond cloud
the goal is to create the totem pole
on the e-file bishop e3
etc
this is such a funny position
this is even funnier than the previous
game
and then the game before that
also this knight is kind of trapped
good evening from germany good to see
you eric
good to see you too triswiss
g5
i don't know if i want to take the
knight
maybe i play rook d1 first
and then pin the knight
or
all i need to do is check the king to
to meet
okay let's start with this move
thank you for doing what you do
oh are you referring to what i'm doing
here
you're welcome
[Music]
thank you euland
okay so now the reason why i didn't take
it first i didn't want the queen to open
up
because there'd be annoying slight
checks
so now when i take after takes i keep
initiative
and if black moves here to defend the
knight then it's made in one
knight four to c5
it's amazing how
all the squares around the king are
controlled by
my various things
okay
the rook has entered the game
uh
this is such a funny position
i think i'll put everything in the
center
i'm controlling the center now i'm also
hitting the king and defending my rook
let's move to a lot of things
i have this move
and so many more things i want to do
[Music]
let's repeat once
okay where's my mate
bishop b2
visit b2
oh no my rook my rook's not defended
ah
98
wait am i not winning
i thought i was mating
i forgot the knight's not defended
oh no
i actually wondered there
i really thought i was meeting
i got a little bit overboard
that's okay i still have rook and the
bishop here
and then knight on d8
i hope this is still okay
what is going on here
bishop here
wait what
i'm so confused now
check
in this move first
e4 is the blind spot for me
check
check
check
uh this might end really badly
i'll be really sad if i lose this
i think i'll just play this move
the knights pinned and the queen is
still restricted
controlling all these squares
the bishop also can't really get out
which means that rook can't get out
all fox things are
stuck despite the fact i'm down
a queen and rook for a bishop
locks up 11 points of material
but i'm the one controlling more squares
it's not even easier for black to sack
anything
yeah i think i'll just calmly play a3
and now i'm threatening i think this is
made in two threats
oh this should be force mate
no mercy anymore
there's king okay there's two different
king moves
of king here i have knight c5 and here
and i fork
this is such a funny game
of king here i play i just control the
center
what a game
uh
check oh it's a fun windmill
check
i'm not interested in winning the queen
check
check okay maybe i am
okay
i'm sure i miss force mate somewhere
around here
right
where's my mate
knight d4 check
uh
sawfish just wants me to develop
i haven't played this
[Music]
move yeah i should not have
been too fancy there
oh i did have horsemates
wait this was brilliant
i just didn't see king jake's knight so
i kind of freaked out
i had f3 check
but ben feingold told me never play f3
g4 king f4 in 1996 checkmate
that would have been so beautiful
oh okay
at least i still won that game
what do we call this
oh no my queen gabbit
or epic beautifulness
[Music]
so these are my games so far staffer
gambit versus
a band engine user these will be the
future youtube
video chapters
okay so i'm four out of four
if we include that first game that i got
refunded
uh
let's play d4 let's find the game
why is everyone playing d6 i'll play
this move
i was gambling a pawn
but now
now i'm using the pond for
for goodness
okay we have another like really weird
opening this is like a queen's gambit
combined with a grub
[Music]
okay this is my uh
i can attempt at sagging upon
so i played g6 to try and uh yeah create
a
a tender point in black's position
now the only way to defend the pawn is
to play king f7
and now now i have ideas of knight e5
play c5 and still going for 95.
okay already looking really really
pleasant i could take with queen
it'll take with knight
i could snag the rook
but my knight is probably more valuable
than the rook
so
let's play h5
okay this pawn is attacked
bishop e3
i just want the queen side castle
together rook to g1
etc
i could win a pawn here
and then lose a pawn
and then queen c4
[Music]
i think it's okay
oh i'm hitting c7 as well
these games are so funny so far
it's been a while since i've done one of
these like streams where i just
try and play a gamut every game
this is too much fun
okay now i can play this move
where's my mate
i could also take this first
hi can you play the young 4b
qh4 stafford one day
oh um
i'll have to look at that a little bit
more closely
but probably
i could take the other rook maybe i
should
also just take the pawn
[Music]
someday i want a castle
but now the bishop's attacked
could castle kingside
i could take this thing
and then take this thing
yeah it was a good choice from earlier
keeping my knight
on the board
okay another delayed bomb cloud
not quite not quite the real thing but
close enough
okay i could force a queen trade
uh
i might as well
[Music]
upper rookie or win a free queen oh 94.
what the move
wonder if black had
seen that from afar
wow
one whole year
oh happy one whole year
wait this isn't so simple
i'll start with this move
what do i do with my thing
e4
maybe this move first
um
i could play this move
i thought it was gonna be an easy win
but now my night is stuck
but i have this move it should be okay
as long as night can get out i'll be up
the exchange
yeah and now i'm ready for this and then
probably some invasion
a big problem for black as the knight is
tied down to the pawn
okay
this move
look at this move first
of king b7 i play a4 and trap the rook
okay where's my mate
it's really close
i'm threatening made in one
so now i have six i have this move
and
now this move
there's rookie seven
i can take this
i came here at a good time oh welcome
you came in a very good time
[Music]
it's just a question how to
finish things off
oh if night moves is mate
hey okay
oh
what was this game
that was a fun game
back to tournament
i don't even know what to call these
like these gambit things
g4 g5
like a g6
okay working my way up in the world
um if i want to win this tournament i
should probably start berserking
would you play a 52-game match against
ding i'd be happy to if he
if he wants to invite me to a tournament
okay let's play b5
someone settle sullivan gambit so i'm
gonna try and transpose into another
sullivan
[Music]
oh
no sullivan for me i'm still gathering a
pawn though
i think i'll play e6
c3
opponents playing very safely i take on
e4
taking on e4 isn't so good though
maybe i'll start with b4
a3
i really want to play this move
we need to invent the rose and gambit
yeah although gambits aren't invented
they're discovered
except maybe some of these gambits are
invented
oh
this is really risky i'm playing
international master
if g3 i'll be happy but there's king
moves
yeah i thought the point was now i have
queen of four
so even against the fellow i am i'm
getting some
absolute uh craziness
white's taking time here
i want to play b3 but my queen is
attacked by the bishop
and the king might even hide on a2
eventually
so i'll take with check if bishop d3 i
take this pawn
queen d3
yeah i think now i throw in this move
this is so funny
i want to play this move now
[Music]
ah but then queen e2
[Music]
i just don't want white to ruin my fun
oh no there's no queen e2
there's bishop d2
i played this move
oh okay
i mean it'll be worse here but it's all
about white's king being
lightly out in the open
without too many clothes on
usually the king likes to be sheltered
by its pawns but here it's the king
sheltering the pawns
yeah my dear was this move
but then here
thank you eric for funny and instructive
chess hope to see you in reykjavik open
oh
hey icelandic noob welcome back
i've been meaning to dm you but uh
yeah thanks for for being here
i'll be
i'll be going to iceland
at the end of this month
we also have an iceland command if
there's anyone that wants to learn more
about the tournament
uh there should be a live broadcast
every day it's also an open tournament
so
um
yeah i think there is there's almost 300
players signed up now
[Music]
i'm trying to get all the crazy weird
chats out of my system
before i play no tv tournament
okay well b3 is now a bit weak
uh
i mean that 5 bishop d3
is rook b8
it's a weird position because like the
normal principles of like developing and
counseling
they're still somewhat relevant but
not as relevant when there's a king here
and
um it calls for a lot of like quick
initiative
i want to play this move
it'd be cool to like sack a queen and
then mate with a pawn but
i don't think that's ever going to
happen
[Music]
you could play f5
bishop d6
maybe i'll go for c5 eventually
still a situation where white's king
isn't completely out of the woods
have this move
yeah no way i'm trading queens
now this or this can come with tempo
next move
unless y plays g4
g4 queen h3
oh but then bishop f1
uh-oh
oh but then queen h6
knight here
this is really terrifying
okay i'll play this move i think g4
would have just crushed me
i'm still down a piece
for a pawn
i have this move i also have this move
oh what's going on
okay i'll play
i'll play this
so i can't castle because then i get
mated
but the king i think is somewhat safe
in the center
do i sack my queen no
g5
queen b5
white really wants a queen trade
i have this move
this move looks fun
i'm going to be losing the g pawn but
then rook off f8
doh my knight
okay we're treating it as a gambit
i honestly didn't see that
and my pawn
oh no my favorite gambit is the england
gambit oh hi eric nice to see you again
nice to see you too pijaker welcome back
got the icelandic crowd in the house
okay i'm down two pieces here
two nights for a pawn
but one night is pinned this bishop's
not developed
i'm ready to open the c file
check
yeah this is not gonna
end well i don't think
i am having so much fun playing the
pawns yani as white and the sicilian
dragon as black you have helped me so
much
can you return the favor and help me so
much in this position
oh i'm in trouble now
[Music]
i think i've been in trouble for a while
but
okay let's try and fight
got my connect4
oh no
yes always play f6
i can't play f6 anymore
i promise my king is cut off too
actually there's a lot of problems in
this position
okay well played from white
oh no my king
i didn't mean to gamble my king as a
cool game though
i probably should not have given away
the knight
uh in hindsight
yeah maybe i should have taken and um
only been down one piece
but life goes on
so that was uh
attempted
o sullivan and b5 against
i am
so we're approaching the halfway point
is this where i start tilting and
playing even more crazy gambits
okay england gambit just for everyone
who says england
um
i'll play mainline england
okay so this is like the main line
england
where i give away a queen oh no my queen
the point is to get some kind of cool
counter play
usually involving
i believe it's this move
maybe bishop e5 is a bit more common but
um
yeah i'm down the queen for bishop
knight and pawn
there's rookie 3 here which looks kind
of terrifying
but opponent doesn't go for it
yeah this is a mon hamilton's unbeatable
gambit like he he made this very popular
he actually played this once in a
tournament game too like a serious
tournament game
um just castle
and i don't really want to trade
minor pieces although i might have to
um
yeah
not what i want to do
but i keep the dark straight bishop
defend the pawn
some idea g6 f5
yeah amman's one game in this opening it
was a st louis like gm invitational
tournament
and
it was like
it lasted over a hundred moves
game was against grandmaster steven zerk
at some point the position was drawn
but the man did end up losing the game
so i got the bishop here we might see
this move
after which i i don't want to trade
and
yeah now
now maybe it's just a matter of some
gradual improvements
h5h4 is one idea
king g7 rook h8
i'm up about a minute on the clock so i
i guess i sacked a queen for a time
advantage
some idea yeah bishop g4
if i can ever provoke f3 in this
diagonal becomes a lot more valuable for
me
and if the queen moves there might be
knight f3 or even bishop f3
thank you migueli
uh
what to do
a5 i don't know what to do here
f5
maybe rook here
i'm dreaming of someday playing this
this and then knight c4
i'll start with a5
oh so white took the pawn
okay now i can play d5
i did see the pawn was hanging um but
now the bishop is probably going to
regret its its decisions
because if takes and i i play knight f3
and this would be a pork
because there's a pin and a fork
and meanwhile all these squares are weak
around the king
so let's have some fun here
i can start with this
knight f3 check was also possible but i
think bishop f3
um
is just a better piece on f3 and then i
can do
other things in the position
[Music]
like maybe this move
if queen f6 i'll play with d6
or no my bishop's hanging
between f6 maybe knight d2
okay
it's incredible like how
how white being up a queen can be
a bit overpowered by
the black pieces
but just as i say that my knight is
is really lacking squares
there's bishop e2
i just sack the knight and then
i'm seriously considering stacking the
knight here
but it's not a good move
yeah i think i'll play rook c6
idea takes and then i'll take back with
rook
to hit the queen
and
uh no i will not sign your baby
i only sign chess boards and
uh
very occasionally posters
but i'm not really a baby signer
bishop e2
bishop here
my boom
i was gonna say my plan is here and here
but
unfortunately rooks can't move like
knights
so c2 is probably a goner
the ultimate plan is to teleport my rook
to h1
but it takes some effort
oh shall i make a rosen poster
i could make a rosen poster
would people buy that
wow if i take this pawn there's this
move
i used to have a banana poster
it was like the chest banana
um
i'm so conflicted here
but now okay so i have rook and bishop
for queen and pawn
and white has finally played f3 but i'm
probably gonna lose this pawn
but maybe it's okay because then i win
the spawn
there's one check and then king h7
if queen f6 i
probably play bishop e6
now no more good checks
idea rookie two and then threatening
maiden three
uh let's be careful here
white might go for a mate
like rook d8
the thing is i'm going to be the one
mating first
because bishop c4
now this is not a good move to pre-move
because white does have
rook d3
oh i missed maiden one
oops
i missed made in one because i saw made
in like one two three four
i also miss maiden two rook c one was
made in two or e one was made in one
what to do
i have to be a little bit flashy
okay
back
back on a win
what was that england gambit
oh no my queen
i have to make a mon hamilton proud it's
blizzard
and now let's play
oh the rosin gambit what's up irene
i'll play a danish gabbat
there's got to be some people that like
the danish
or like danish pastries
okay now playing a goring gambit
the one issue with playing gambits is
sometimes people just decline them
trying to insist take my pawn
take it take it you know you want to
thanks for the great content oh thank
you d freeman
i'm just gonna leave the pawn here
someday bach will take it
someday
but maybe the day will never come
i mean i could try sagging more pawns
but let's be
let's be normal first
b4 play b4
i'm really furious here
box not taking the pawn
i've never been so angry
i can't trap the bishop anymore
[Music]
i'm threatening this pawn if castling
i'll play bishop h6
some idea e6 as well
now if i play f4 then black will be
incentivized to take and check
uh
the e6 now
e6
the whole game these pawns are gonna
have a staring contest
who's gonna blink first
i'm close to blinking
takes
i'll keep my knight here
i don't want to blink
after this move
maybe this move
is white gonna play d3
but then i take the knight
oh no
oh that was a good move
wait this is really bad
hey eric i have a question for you i
have been playing chess for about a year
now and can't break 800. any tips
um don't hang your pieces
it's actually a legit tip at that level
like a lot of it is just minimizing
blunders
oh what do i do
and i berserked this game black finally
took the pawn
i'm so sad now though
i'm just down a whole rook
but i'm treating it as a gambit this
rook is doing nothing in the corner
and now i take and i'm threatening stuff
really i'm just writing a single check
but hopefully black
panics and loses
what am i threatening
thank you anton
oh and thank you mr week's tv
uh
[Music]
yeah it's easier to answer questions
when i'm not in time best openings to
play without castling
again it's easier to answer questions
when i'm not in time trouble
and knock down a rook
and you can play any opening without
castling but
in some openings you'll get more
punished than others
check
i'm just gambling upon because why not
let's go it's a triple pork quadruple
pork
i have 10 seconds though
oh no my time
i'm getting a scam call
let's go
let's go i miss maiden one
i may have missed made in one
but i got the job done
[Music]
oh i missed made in one queen g if i was
mate
i was freaking out i was a long time
okay what opening was that
that was a
danish gambit staring contest
okay
back in business baby
i have 21 tournament points
leader has 44.
uh i'll play whatever this is
i had this similar thing earlier but not
quite the same
[Music]
i tried gamuting the g pawn
eric the multi-tasker already making
youtube chapter names
yeah i'm still gonna have to add
timestamps but it's okay
also this knight was just trapped
okay so this is an opening success i
want a piece
after
after nine moves
i want to play this move
look at this move
it's so pretty
and then this
and after takes takes takes this takes
such a funny line
so now i'm up a whole rook
yeah that wants a castle
i'd like to prevent black from castling
but
it's not so easy
i think i'll just move back
and enjoy my
position up a rook
let me trade some bishops
oh let's give black funny pawns
okay black has a tetris piece pawns now
i'm losing c2
[Music]
maybe i should have thought more
thoroughly
but then i win this
okay now here
i just want the castle
i also kind of want to give black
quadruple pawns
but that's
probably a bit more difficult
and take
this okay no quadruple pawns for black
no more tetris piece for black
oh no my rook oh no
but it's uh it's like early christmas
you receive presents and you give
presents
and then you receive more presents
as long as you weren't naughty
yeah if takes i i check here and then
uh it's almost smothered mate
yeah queen d6 holds on to the pawn but
then f4
ah queen d6 is less fun
i have this move
this knight is pinned
what to do here
queen
i'm up a full rook so i shouldn't be
like too crazy
there's this move
takes takes takes
maybe this move
defending f2 so after takes takes
f2 is defended e4 is defended
this knight is actually really nicely
placed on d3
and king has more breathing room now
okay still up a full rook
was i ever down material this game
i was down the pond very temporarily
until the night got trapped
okay um
yeah this is completely winning for
white
e6 will be the next next victim
uh be careful
king f8
so is white's mother black's writing
made in two maiden one
not even made in two
as long as i'm giving checks
maybe this move
i'm defending from afar
is what we call discover defense
i just want to set up smother mate
oh how do you send a message with prime
the first step is to sub with prime
if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free
you usually have to sub a few months in
a row to send a sub message
okay
oh it's really close to meat
but not quite
but is it
so if rook takes its meaning
[Music]
if here
it's not quite meeting
which is kind of frustrating
which also kind of rhymes
i think i'll start with this move
wait did my knight just come from there
i know i just came from there but the
idea is i'm blocking this check
wait
uh how do i do this
check
i've only played knight seven once right
okay
um
so we're not repeating
if i check here
there's a cool idea
ah i can okay
i don't want to play 95 because that
would actually repeat
but i can play this
so now i block the queen
and when i take i'll pin the rook
and the other line i was scared of rook
f2 but the rook is pinned
and now if the queen or the rook
takes then
okay here i'm getting my uh
i'm hoping i'm getting some other mate
and if it takes and it's still winning
yeah all i want to do is smother mate
but
black's not giving me the satisfaction
we might see queen f4
hoping that i don't see queen digs out
for her
yeah carlson once tried this against me
but it didn't work
okay uh
what do we call this bronstein gambit
the bronstein gambit
the black declined it black was just
pre-moving in the opening
okay
brownstein
gambit
almost leads to smothered meat
blizzard oh
how do i play against this
i think jonathan trunks has a video on
how to
[Music]
how to deal with this
it's hard to gambit when blocks or
white's not uh
developing the bishops
but here we go play this move
ah let's play this move
and then this move
is this even a gabbit
like queen's not hanging here
i play this move
uh
i think i have to take the bishop
even though i don't want to
wait now i'm the one winning a pawn
what just happened
i'm up upon
okay i think i'll gab it back
nah let's keep taking stuff
i guess this game i'm the one accepting
the gambit
uh
oh i really want to do things with my
rook
castle
wait
no let's develop
i gotta play a lot
quicker because we both berserked
time is gonna be really relevant
i like the structure though
we could trade
rook b8 first
okay we'll trade
i'd see seven
idea knight d5
and probably this move
hmm
this move
okay it's slightly confusing position
but
i do have a nice pawn
this square is very
very nice for a knight
also this square it's two outpost
squares
threatening the fork
maybe had this move
although it doesn't quite work
i go play this move
idea c4 i'm defending d4
and if takes i take because there's a
pin
i'm leaving this pawn
[Music]
left alone
but hopefully for good reason
oh no my rook
yeah if we trade rooks and i'll be
threatening maiden one
gotta move a lot quicker
oh this is a funny position
the king is so close to getting mated
uh but where's my meat
let's go okay
that was a weird one
[Music]
that was like a
gambit
double fianchetto weird
yeah a bit weird time scramble
thing
okay
16th place
so i have one loss
one legitimate loss
and then one loss to an engine user
i'll be zerk again
this time i'll go back to e4
and i'll play a wing gambit
thank you flaccadori
okay wing gambit combined with grand
prix attack
uh
probably not a great combination
but i do have center
so bishop d3
can't complain with this i might play h4
soon
i'll take with knight
maybe i should have taken with bishop
probably should have taken with bishop
although maybe not because the bishop is
controlling
defending f4
okay hitting the queen
queen b4 bishop d2
queen a7
and then i need to find a way to defend
bishop b4
let's start with this
because if we trade bishops then my
knight has a
um just easier access to d6
and the queen is still hit
a request for england i already played
in england so far i'm trying to play a
different gambit every every game
uh these are all the different things
i've played so far
[Music]
okay this one's working out quite nicely
f5
idea queen
g5 wow f6
let's play c4
the pawn tension must be increased
also my pawns must smile
oh
[Music]
i don't know what to do there's too many
fun looking options
there there
i really don't know what to do
maybe just this move
pawns are actually smiling now
i'm giving back the d5 square but this
knight is really well reinforced
and now the plan is to take play this
and eventually mate
even if it involves like giving away a
bishop
um
[Music]
not sure if it works
i want to make it work
i should probably save the bishop first
i really wanted to play queen h6 but the
problem was uh
knight takes g3 and pawn takes c5 and
then my knight would be loose
but with bishop e4 now i
the bishop's actually really useful here
and the pawn survives
at least for the moment
thank you mo cousin
and now this knight's pinned and tied
down to defending the other knight
now i play this move
so i'm threatening this this and mate
i don't really see how black defends
the king can't really run away unless
like this move is played
but then i'll still win the rook
oh i could have played queen jigs before
because this and this were pinned right
okay here we go
if here it's made in one
and if here it's made in one
okay that was a fun game
that was a sicilian wing gambit
leading to 23 move checkmates
sicilian wing gambit
leads to 23 move win
okay
13th place
leader has 54 points
berserking and winning a lot
but just lost her streak i might play
the the person in first place actually
i'll probably berserk
oh never mind
still berserking
okay uh
i want to play a gambit but is this a
gambit this might be a gambit
can i just sack a knight
let's sack a knight for the lulls
because then i'll get um it's like a
halloween
i'll get a lot of pawns
maybe this move
and then take
and
then
this move
okay
i'm down a piece but i have a lot of
center pawns
actually just two center pawns
but a lot of supporting pawns
uh i was about to lose a queen
that could have been tragic i might have
to play a6 here
also play f5
f f5 is interesting
allowing bishop b5 wow c4
what does c4
[Music]
move the queen back
yeah i might end up losing the pawn but
okay maybe not
i was writing this
be very very quiet
i was hoping for this move
oh
okay
i think i'll still play this because why
not and then queen a6
i was really hoping for knight d7 and
then i'd
i'd be winning the white queen but
okay
um
it still feels like i have some
compensation
delayed reverse bond cloud my rooks are
connected
pawn is now defended this pawn is now
attacked
f6 is almost there's funny line bishop
e2 defending the pawn f6 trapping the
queen
how else does white defend the pawn
please play king 2 or bishop e2
oh queen e2
play this move
i think i'm going to sack a pawn
[Music]
because i much prefer if the d-file
opens
even though i'm
i just gave away a key center pong
uh the fact that d files open is
it's nice because i have a target on d2
now
now f6
objectively i'm much worse here
but practically
oh no my rook
yeah i'm regretting giving away a pawn
on d4 so i'm trying to get that pawn
back to d4
but white's not taking it
if i take
i gotta watch my time
um
okay
i've changed my mind i'd rather save my
rooks
b5 incoming
thread is b4
d2 is a the ultimate target
wow
wow
okay somehow this is working out even if
i don't deserve it
i'll put the bishop all the way in the
corner
and hopefully white forgets about it
uh don't hurt me
please forget about my bishop
yes okay
hey i i'm using both of the corners
long distance relationship
okay
that's a very powerful long distance
relationship
uh what gambit was at
that was like a alakine
weird alakine
needs to powerful
long distance relationship
these are going to be some weird youtube
chapters
if you're watching in the future on
youtube
let me know if you've made it this far
and let me know what your favorite game
was so far
also if you're watching on twitch thanks
for watching
[Music]
don't forget to subscribe with prime
uh
i forgot to gambit okay let's play this
move i tried to play benoni gabbat
a lot of people here
good to see people
okay what is this opening i'm just
moving pawns
let's keep moving pawns
what's this a rosen trophy there's a
rosen trophy if you move pawns for the
first
how many moves is it 12
i think it's 12 moves
oh no oh i have f6 though
okay white had made in two there
i had made in two
i thought bad things were going to
happen to me
oh
the problem is i'm still losing here
maybe this move
this is a really bad position
[Music]
i hope there's no small children
watching
or small animals
king of seven i guess
[Music]
i mean my rook's hanging but if white
takes a rook then i win the night so
[Music]
best case scenario i'm down to exchange
and down a ton of time
okay seven
28
and queenie might actually make some
sense
don't hurt me don't do it
don't you dare
if we trade queens i undevelop my king
okay hitting the queen and defending the
rook still attacking the knight as well
[Music]
and somehow this knight's defended so
there's no queen b6 to counter attack
there's that movement i kind of forgot
about
um
i'm in big trouble here
still
[Music]
queen e6
the a3
[Music]
bishop d4 i'll take it
there's also knight g5 here which
terrifies me as well
okay now the knight and bishop are
hanging
even though i might be developing my
king a little bit
i don't see mate
it might be getting needed
if g4 i on basant or i take with bishop
don't hurt me
okay let's defend
probably should not have taken that rook
i couldn't help myself though
[Music]
it's up three pawns
oh my knight
yeah unfortunately
the tricks didn't quite work there
but you never know
oh no my king
[Music]
oh no
that was unfortunate
i thought it was really close too
when we got to uh
this position i was hitting the queen
and threatening mate
but yeah bishop three and c5 were good
moves
rook age one was not stalemate
uh
of course this is my one last idea my
king always has a square
oh together trophy i need 12 move
12 pawn moves and then a win oh no
[Music]
12
pawn move opening gambit
what should i do
oh can you show the maiden two in the
beginning
uh
it was queen h5 rook h5 bishop takes h5
mate
okay let's play a tennis and gambit
what is this knight c6
why is no one accepting my gambit today
a lot of people are declining things
can i play this move
uh
i just gamma the whole piece
i'm in the gamble the whole piece
because there's one trap i'm seeing
and i strengthened my center too
okay i was hoping for a bishop g4 and i
get some compensation
um this is a little bit more speculative
but even though i'm down a piece
uh
i have center
which maybe offers some compensation
bishop here
probably not wise to pre-move that
[Music]
okay
try and lift the rook over
yeah this is not a good position
[Music]
but this is what i get for for playing
chess like this
um
take
it's taken here
yeah my compensation is kind of just
evaporating
still some initiative though
b7 is a bit tender
like castle queen side
get both rooks
to the center files
black is for the most part
underdeveloped
wow
allowing queen h1
okay it's getting weird
it's getting really weird
the queen is kind of stuck now
[Music]
not completely stuck but
kind of stuck
on c4 is hanging
what to do
[Music]
play this move
i don't think i'm getting mated
or am i
i might be
don't do it
i got mated oh no
oh
i should play rookie too
because i was i was threatening mate in
two
but
black was threatening made in one
oh no
famous last words
i have 40 points
leader has 60.
okay i'll try and finish in top
top ten let's let's have a go top ten
uh
tennyson gambit
oh no my pieces and king
okay
oh this one again
[Music]
wait how do i sack stuff
this
ah okay let's have some fun
oh no my bishop
i mean i'm gonna win back
multiple things
and by multiple things i mean more than
one thing
okay this this is working out nicely
it feels good when you try and like sack
stuff and the opponent
is is the one winding up down a lot of
material
okay so i'm up on rook knight in pawn
for a bishop
okay now just stop working pawn
[Music]
oh blinking f1
some idea
[Music]
um
and the goal is to try and convert this
quickly and cleanly
or quickly and
dirtily
get a move i did not see coming
i have this move
i have to be careful here
queen d3 king one
i'm kind of making a mess out of this
c4
the most likely result is i went on time
okay i'll take the pawn
defend the bishop
i don't have casting rights sadly
i'm allowing rookie too
my king will find a safe haven and the
knight will survive
oh
[Music]
if black plays this i'm i'm objectively
not better here
it's objectively a draw
okay
oh
that was a weird one that was early
g5
bishop
f7 find this
is fun is so weird
the state of foo
oh what is this
this is like a wayward queen attack
oh this is so fun oh
white gave me a taste of my own medicine
wait what just happened
we did the same thing to each other
what is this
i play this move
oh it's gonna play this
i can do the same thing i can also do
this first
i think i'll do this first
attacking defending and still
threatening
oh but then there's knight d2
uh
what is this game
oh i should have taken with a pin
take and
check white's queen is a bit stuck
what is happening this game
i'm up at night somehow
so that's good
i could take the bishop i could also
take here
threatening this
the triple pork
the knight is pinned
um not mating
i might as well
[Music]
of take sirs take some takes if i have
to take this way
i'm up a whole night
but the question is how do i
finish the attack
i want to lift the rook
there
there
what to do
there's a funny line
um
that move is actually really annoying
there there
okay i have a really no it doesn't work
i thought i had a funny idea
maybe i'll just play this move
it's a sad move though
oh i have a funny idea
it doesn't work though
or does it
it might work
no it doesn't work
it's a funny line though
i'm losing my queen but so is white
now we're just getting an end game
where i'm down the pawn
and my knight's gonna be in the corner
what just happened
oh thank you punter face
uh
i guess i play a4
[Music]
and not too many options here
i have a four on three majority
this is probably going to be the last
game
i have to be careful not to get made it
this first
dna of seven
this is really risky i'm asking to get
checkmated basically
don't mimi
okay
i had made in two there was this insane
me then two i'll share after the game
this is stressful
i'm gonna play this move
so white white could have played b3
b3 takes and then mate
i don't think i've ever seen that sort
of pattern ever
and now b3 i take
and now
[Music]
i take
oh no
yeah this game's not going to count for
the tournament
oh that's a really good move
before
this move first
knights are really tricky creatures
also very majestic creatures
holding on
feels like i'm walking a tightrope here
fall off at any moment
good move
really good move
what to do
white played well
i could promote to the
how do i do it rook
there's cases where you should promote
tarok to
and hope say pre-move something but
this is a sad ending
uh but who knows
you see a miracle
oh i got opposition
[Music]
good game
this is a the game where we both like
did the thing to each other
and i was up a piece
but after h4 i kind of just froze
good trick to know in the future i don't
know if you can do this every time like
this
because you you see black still has a
pawn here
it's pretty rare that black has played
g5
on move one
i think after h4 i was in a
a bit of a bind maybe black is still
better somehow
[Music]
i had to find rook to hate
rookie here
uh yeah i considered rook t8
rook d8 it's nice because
um
basically there were two issues with h5
one was
this potential skewer but if here i just
move the king
the other issue was after takes takes my
knight would be hanging but the rook on
d8 defends the knights and if c3 i move
back and defend the rook missed most of
the stream will this go on youtube
uh
yes